Up first, the kill test.
Doug?
To see what kind of lethal
damage your halberd will do,
we'll take your
halberd and deliver
thrust, hacks, and
attempt to dismount
that dummy with its hook.
Phil, you're up first.
Are you ready for this?
Yes, sir.
Let's do this.
I spent a long time
making that thing
and I want to see it work.
All right, Phil,
your spear tip
is sharp, not only at the
point but its edges also.
Your ax head, not only did
it begin and break the ribs,
it went in and cut
the internal organs
that were behind the ribs.
And your hook blade,
it dug into the ribs
and dismounted the
dummy from the horse.
Overall, your weapon
here will kill.
- Thank you.
- Good job.
All right, Jonathan,
you're up next.
You ready?
- Let's do it.
My halberd's a brute.
I'm excited to hear Doug
tell me it will kill.
That will make my son happy.
I want to see some
blood and gore and guts.
All right, Jonathan, on
the thrust your spear tip
right here penetrated deep and
created a deep wound channel.
Your ax head here,
pretty much it was just
the tip that penetrated
into the chest,
and also it's the diaphragm.
Your hook broke the ribs,
got into the organs,
and dismounted the whole
dummy from the horse.
The most important thing
about this whole thing
is it will kill.
All right, bladesmiths,
next up is a strength test.
Ben?
To test the strength and
durability of your halberds,
I will be chopping into
this corrugated sheet steel.
Remember, this test is
all about what the steel
does to your
halberds and not what
your halberds do to the steel.
Phil, you're up first.
You ready?
- Yes, sir.
Well Phil, your halberd
held up perfectly.
All of the faces on it
are still razor sharp.
There's no deformation
that I can see.
Overall, very well done.
Thank you.
Jonathan, you're up.
You ready?
Get you some.
Well Jonathan, on the hits,
your edges held up pretty well.
I don't see any
problems with them.
The one thing that does
concern me is the blade
has taken a bit of a
bend to one side here,
but the edges and the
points seem to have done
pretty well in the penetration.
The whole thing held
up, still solid.
Well done.
Phil, Jonathan, you've
both done some amazing work
on your German halberds,
and they performed
very well in our weapons tests.
However, in this arena
of competition only
the best weapon can win.
And our next "Forged in
Fire" champion is Phil.
Congratulations, you are our
new "Forged and Fire" champion.
Jonathan, unfortunately your
weapon did not make the cut.
Ben Abbott's going
to tell you why.
Jonathan, at the end of the
day your halberd was heavy,
more difficult to wield, and
took a bend in the strength
passed, and for those
reasons we had to let you go.
Jonathan, please
surrender your weapon.
I feel honored
to have competed
with Phil and the other two
guys in this competition.
I had a good time.
If you do compete
in this, be ready.
Have your skills on point
because you will be tested.